all right we're now on problem number 15
on page 463 so 15.
let's see they have a chart and it says
city
and
noon temperature in fahrenheit so i'll
just write temperature
temperature
and city a
is 50 degrees
b
is 33.
c
is 27.
d
d is
t degrees
t degrees e
is 68. degrees
f
is
44 degrees
and g
is
40 degrees
all right now the question says the
table above shows the noon temperature
for seven cities uh designate a through
g all right if the median noon
temperature so the median
the median
is
40 degrees
40 degrees that's the median then the
noon temperature for city d could be any
of the following except so the median
means what it means the middle number it
means if we were to rearrange all of
these numbers from smallest to highest
the 40 would be the middle so let's
let's rearrange
all the numbers i guess except for t
from smallest highs because we don't
know what t is so see the smallest is
33 another smallest is 27 then we go to
27 33 we have 40
then we have
50. and then we have 68 right i should
have written
six numbers down and i wrote six numbers
down right and they're saying the median
is 40.
so in order for the median to be 40 this
needs to be the middle number right the
middle number that means there need to
be just as many numbers smaller than 40
as there are numbers larger than 40.
right
just the way i do it right now it's not
it doesn't look like the median right
because there's only two numbers less
than it and there's three numbers
greater than it
so i think you see where this is going t
has to be someplace here
t has to be someplace less than 40
degrees in order for 40 to be the median
number
so let's see it says and actually t
could be less than or equal to 40
because even if if we had another 40
here
then 40 would still be the median right
because if you put all the numbers in
order you know you have seven numbers
the the fourth highest number would
still be 40. so t has to be less than or
equal to 40.
so if we look at the choices a is 29
well that satisfies it b is 35 that
satisfies it c is 39 satisfies it d is
40. and then we look at e e is 42. so
that does not satisfy it so our choice
is e
e
all right problem number 14. this one
looks exciting
and i will do an exciting color
so let's see let me see if i can draw
this
so i have a line on the top
and then i have a line that goes
straight down like that
and then this thing goes like
this
something like this
and it goes something like this
you can draw this right
draw this even
and then it goes well
close enough i think
to what they have on the drawing
let me fill in all the information
so it says these are right angles
this is right angle
length of this is six
the length of this is six length of this
is six
and then it tells us that these are 30
degrees
30 degrees
it says what is the perimeter of the
figure above so in order to figure out
the perimeter we know this side we know
this side we know this side we need to
figure out these two sides right
these two sides so once we know those
and then we're set
and and you know you could do some fancy
things here if you wanted to go in the
wrong direction but you'd get the right
answer you could make you know 30 60 90
triangle here
and here and you know figure out this
side and then figure out the hypotenuse
et cetera et cetera but the real trick
of this is just kind of seeing the
negative image here trying to see kind
of what hasn't been drawn
and i'll show you what i mean
if we draw
let's just draw a little
line here and i think now you'll start
to see what i'm doing
if we have a if if there's a line here
what what's this angle
well this this whole thing is a right
angle it's 90 degrees so this angle
would be 60 right
and so this angle this angle would also
be 60 degrees
and so with this angle
right because they have to add up to 180
and if two of them are 60 the third one
is going to be 60. so what do we know
about this triangle right here
well it's an equilateral triangle all
the sides are the same because all the
angles are the same
well we know one of the sides we know
this side we made up because it's going
to be the same length as this side up
here so this is going to be 6.
well if that side is six then all of the
sides of this equilateral triangle we
made are going to have to be six
all right
and then we're done now we just have to
add up all the sides
so it's
six plus six plus six plus six plus six
right we ignore this one this isn't part
of the perimeter the perimeters are the
purple side so it's 1 2 3 4 5 6's so 5
times
6 is equal to
30.
choice d
all right
problem number 15
problem
number 15.
m is the greatest prime factor of 38. m
greatest
prime
of 38
n is the greatest prime factor of a
hundred
and
greatest
prime
of
what is the value of m plus n
well
for without knowing a trick here and the
trick hasn't just jumped into my head
let's just try to factor them do the
prime factorization
so
it is and actually do the easiest way to
do the prime factorization is
well
look we want to get the greatest prime
factor and this one's actually pretty
easy because you have 2
and then it's 2 times what
2 times
19. we're done that was pretty easy
right 2 times 19 19 is the greatest
prime factor of 38 100 might take us a
little bit
more time right because it's 2 times 50
right 100 is 2 times 50 50 is 2 times 25
25 is 5 times 5. actually that didn't
take us much time either this is just a
straight i thought there might be a
trick here but this is just a straight
prime factorization problem so the
greatest prime factor
of a hundred
is five
you add them together nineteen plus five
nineteen plus 5
is equal to 24
and that is choice c
okay let's see if i have time to fit in
problem number 16 otherwise i'll do it
in the next video
line l has a positive slope and pass it
let me draw coordinate axes
so that's my y axis
that's my x axis and i'm going to draw
another line in a different color see
has a positive slope so that means it's
going to go from you know the bottom
left to the top right
and it goes through the point 0 0 so
this is line l
line l looks something like that
so this is line
l
if line k is perpendicular to line l
which of the following must be true so
it intersects at a perpendicular
angle so line k is going to look
something let me do it a different color
line k is going to look something like
this right it's perpendicular
perpendicular
line k
so this
so
and i have a feeling that this is going
to go into something that you just need
to know that the perpendicular if you if
you know the slope of something let's
say line l's slope let's say
l
let's say you know let's say that this
is y is equal to mx plus b but we know
it goes through the intercept so it's
actually just mx
then we know that line k
line k
right here
is going to have
the negative inverse of the slope of
line l so it's going to be negative 1
over m
x
and then plus b we this could this could
you know intersect right here we don't
know because they didn't tell us it goes
through the origin so we don't know what
b is b could be zero but the bottom line
is the only thing we do know is that if
this number is positive
this number
is going to be negative and they told us
that this is positive right
and let's see choice a
line k passes through zero zero no no oh
c choice c line k has a negative slope
and that's all we know
see in the next video